(rap music)
- [Interviewer] Gabrielle,
where'd you grow up?
Where you from?
- [Gabrielle] From Houston, Texas.
- [Interviewer] Houston.
And tell me about your family.
You grow up with both of your parents?
- Both of my parents were incarcerated.
Dad had three life sentences.
Mom kept getting locked
up for prostitution so
my grandma and grandfather raised me.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
How was your childhood?
- My childhood was good.
My childhood was good.
It was, kinda took us fast
'cause they real old-fashioned.
We didn't get to do
everything everybody else did.
It's like school, church, and home.
No going out, nothing.
- [Interviewer] Maybe being
with your grandparents
might have been a better move than being
with your real parents.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, you know,
things that we didn't get to
do, I'm like, "Wow," you know.
"When I get to start
knowing things," you know.
I'm kinda rebellious, so, yeah,
I'm gonna sneak out the window.
You wouldn't let us do anything.
- [Interviewer] What were
your parents in prison for?
- My dad was
I think he capital murder
or something like that.
So he got three life sentences.
- [Interviewer] What about Mom?
- Mom kept gettin' busted
with cocaine and prostitution,
multiple prostitution charges.
- [Interviewer] So, after
you left your grandparents...
- I got kicked out at 15
'cause I got pregnant.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- And I had the baby
and I thought the man was in love with me,
but he's 70 years old so,
course, he didn't show up to the hospital.
- [Interviewer] How old was he?
- He was 70, I'm 15.
- [Interviewer] He was 70?
(Gabrielle murmurs in agreement)
- [Interviewer] And you were 15?
- I thought that, you know,
we were gonna make it work
but that was a lie.
I have seven now.
I have seven kids now.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
And did you raise your kids?
- I raised three, three of the seven.
Most of my kids are biracial.
So my oldest daughter said that
he was too friendly with her down there.
We went through all this
litigations, and I lost all my kids.
Most of my mind, too
'cause I really don't know
what I really missed with that.
I'm with them 24/7.
But I believe him.
She my daughter, so
kind of like a rock and hard place there.
- [Interviewer] So
where are your kids now?
- They're in Texas.
They're all in the system.
- [Interviewer] They're in the system?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you?
- 28.
- [Interviewer] You're 28.
And you've been out here
in Skid Row for how long?
- Five months.
- [Interviewer] Ah, so you're brand new.
You came straight from Texas or...
(Gabrielle murmurs in agreement)
So you're fairly new to L.A.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Welcome
to the worst part of L.A.
- Belly of the beast.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And where you staying now?
(Gabrielle mumbles)
- [Gabrielle] I'm staying
where I can stay, you know?
SRO sometimes, you know, sometimes I...
- [Interviewer] Wherever you
can find a place to sleep.
- [Gabrielle] Build me a cardboard house,
keep from getting any scents.
There's only one door.
I make another one easily, but anyways.
- [Interviewer] Getting into
a tent is dangerous sometimes?
- [Gabrielle] Yeah, yeah, it's dangerous.
- [Interviewer] And
then, what's your drug?
- [Gabrielle] Cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Crack?
- [Gabrielle] Crack cocaine.
- [Interviewer] When
did you start with that?
- [Gabrielle] 22 with my mom.
We're in a closet.
- [Interviewer] And then, what
are you doing for money now?
- [Gabrielle] Anything I can.
- [Interviewer] You're dating guys?
- [Gabrielle] Dating, yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been arrested out here?
- [Gabrielle] No.
- [Interviewer] You haven't?
And were you doing that in Texas as well?
- [Gabrielle] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And that gets dangerous at times, right?
- [Gabrielle] Yeah, gets really dangerous.
But it's like, you know, the
last couple of weeks down here,
you know, I have me
three, four dollars trying
to get me something in a different mode,
you know what I mean?
(mumbles) like, "Oh,
yeah, c'mon little mama."
They'll help me out.
They give me like double
what I pay for it,
if not triple.
And when I turn my back to leave,
then all of sudden,
they grab me and stuff.
Hours are no good, it's really dangerous.
You might not make it out.
- [Interviewer] Right.
But if you fast like a cat like me,
you can climb trees and fences.
Good for them.
It's what that is.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What do you think your chances are
of getting off the street
and getting clean from crack
and stuff like that?
(Gabrielle sighs)
- I think I have a fifty-fifty chance.
I'm really hitting strong.
I know I'm better than this.
It's just like I can't
get away from the thrill,
and I really need some help with this.
I don't think I can do it by myself.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think would help you?
- Me?
Mental health?
I need something.
Rehabilitation, maybe even
gettin', going to jail
might save my life, I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Going to
jail seems to be the key
for a lot of people that just
can't do it on their own.
- It's just a way out,
it's just a way out for me.
- [Interviewer] The trick is to stay clean
after you get out of jail.
- Yeah.
It means get expedited home, something.
- [Interviewer] You think
getting back to Texas
would help you?
- I think it would,
but it won't solve the problem
if I'm not there mentally.
I'd go anywhere.
Mind ain't there,
gonna do me no good.
- [Interviewer] Is living
the street life different
in Houston than it is out here?
(Gabrielle murmurs in agreement)
- [Interviewer] How's it different?
- 'Cause I can't walk the
streets after 11 o'clock there.
Guarantee I probably
wouldn't make it back.
- [Interviewer] Why is that?
- 'Cause I mean (mumbles)...
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- Them (mumbles) will
put a bullet in my head
faster there than will here.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is
it more dangerous there?
- Yes.
Can't even walk to the corner store.
Can't do it.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- They really gang bang hard there.
There's no chance I'd make it.
- [Interviewer] You've had
friends lose their lives?
- I got a lot of people that I knew.
They're not here no more.
And they on to me.
- [Interviewer] You talk with
any of your family at all?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Nobody.
- I'm too ashamed.
- [Interviewer] Mom and Dad are gone
or are they still around?
- I don't know about my dad.
I'm kinda scared to know
who he is and everything.
I ain't got in touch with him.
My mom, I talked to her last night
and everything.
I told her I needed a birth certificate
for my GR still pending.
I need my ID for my Social
Security check again.
- [Interviewer] When you were a kid,
did you have dreams of
a different life of...
- Yeah, I had dreams of a family
but I know now that's just a fairy tale.
I make life what it is.
So, you know, I'm my greatest adversary.
I know that now.
If I had just a piece
of hope to hold on to,
I think I could make it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
How do you think living the
street life has changed you?
You've been doing it for...
- I think it's built up a
resilient, a brick wall.
I don't trust nothing nobody tell me,
especially if they got that thing to them,
not like me.
Their broken promises, none of that.
It's like all out the window
when I see them doing what I'm doing
because they ain't about nothing.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- I have associates.
(interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] 'Cause you
can't really trust anyone.
- No.
- [Interviewer] All right, John.
Well, thank you so much for talking to me.
And good luck out there.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And I
hope you figure out a way
out of the, off the street.
- I appreciate that.
- [Interviewer] Thank you for coming by.
- [Gabrielle] You're welcome.
You one of the few.
You never judged me.
You treated me like I'm human.
Humane, I really love that term.
I really do.
I had to get that off my chest.
You listened to me.
You did.
- [Interviewer] All right, Gabby.
Well, thank you for coming
in and talking with me.